are the airpods Pro 2 really worth extra
money over the third generation airpods
well I've been using these new ones for
over a week and these ones for about a
year so I'm gonna let you guys know what
my experience has been based on Apple's
prices there is a 70 difference but the
airpods 3 have been on sale multiple
times for as low as a hundred and thirty
nine dollars and I'll leave a link down
in the video description when these pop
down on sale low and that makes it kind
of tough to pay so much extra money as
far as battery life they seem similar
with six for the earbuds themselves and
30 with a case but if you take a closer
look the airpods pro 2s actually do
better now Apple also gave the airpod
pros to the ability to charge with an
Apple Watch charger now at first when
they announced it I thought that was
just a gimmick but having that ability
to be more flexible so if you have an
Apple Watch charger somewhere maybe in
your truck in your car or if you have
one of the two in the ones that has the
Apple watch and iPhone it is nice to
have that extra flexibility ability now
another thing that is interesting that
most people don't talk about is the fact
that the airpods pro 2's case is also
ipx4 water resistant not just the
earbuds which the airpods three do have
now my first gen airpods Pro the first
pair I got these actually died because
they went into the wash and the case got
messed up so it's nice to have that
extra little bit of protection now they
also added this lanyard feature
personally I don't care about that I
feel like if you have a lanyard on there
it's wobbling around it's you know tied
up to something these can fall out but
you have that now I switched over to the
airpods 3 because of the sound quality
and I'll talk about that in just a bit
but I want to mention Comfort the
airpods Pro 2 have that little rubber
ear tip that seals them into your ear
but they're still quite comfortable and
the vent has been improved so it is
better than most others but I would say
that the airpods 3 are more comfortable
for my ears if I'm using them for more
than two to three hours at a time
overall I think it really depends on
your ear shape and Some people prefer
these While others would like the ear
tips especially with that new extra
small size now another reason why people
like the airpods 3 is the fact that you
still hear outside sounds because it
doesn't seal it in but the airpods pro
have the transparency mode which is now
adaptive and the microphones have been
really improved so you hear everything
just as good as these ones right here
sometimes even better and apple showed
off in loud situations that they could
actually lower that outside sound to
make sure it doesn't damage your hearing
I've only had that happen one time in
real use when my kids dropped something
and I was shocked that it didn't sound
very loud so basically the airpods Pro 2
can be used as hearing protection even
if you hear outside sounds now with that
we have the active noise cancellation
which is insanely good the third gen
airpods let all the sound in so if
you're mowing your lawn for example you
still hear all of that noise and it's
hard to hear your music and it's bad for
your ears these ones will block that out
they do an insanely good job I've never
heard of earbuds that sound anywhere
close to this good and with that I was
in my truck I started up my truck as a
V8 it has to warm up and I thought that
my truck didn't start even though the
dials moved up because it blocked out
all of that sound they do a crazy good
job but it's so convenient having that
feature now I haven't flown to the
airpods Pro 2 just yet typically I will
take my airpods Max but I did some side
by side comparisons and I was shocked by
how close they were early this morning
it was raining like crazy and I compare
them to the airpods max and I was
shocked that the high noises of the
raindrops falling were actually quieter
with the airpods Pro 2 than the airpods
max so if you're somebody that has
dedicated over ears when you fly I think
that the airpod pros 2 will do a good
enough job not to need those at all
another thing I liked about the airpods
3 was the microphone quality it was an
improvement over the original airpods
but now we have these so let's go ahead
and take a look at at three different
scenarios and compare how the
microphones do this is the microphone
quality of Apple's airpods 3 in a room
with some background HVAC noise and this
is a micron quality of Apple's airpods 2
in a regular room with some background
HVAC noise and this is the micro quality
of Apple's airpods 3 with some
background ambient noise like if you're
in a restaurant or a busy Cafe and this
isn't my phone quality of Apple's
airpods Pro 2. if you're in a busy room
or a noisy environment and this is a
micro quality of the airpods 3 if you're
in a windy environment and you have to
be talking on the phone and this is the
microphone quality of Apple's airpods
Pro 2. if you are in a windy environment
and you need to talk on the phone there
you guys go you let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
below I think overall the airpods pro
did great other than that windy
situation where at the end they cut out
for a little bit uh but before that they
sounded wonderful I think it might be
because of the microphones along with
the new Bluetooth that's included so
with that we have the new H2 chip that
is what does all the processing we also
have Bluetooth 5.3 which has better
range it uses less power and I think
that also helps it out but another thing
that it helps with is the ability of the
case to tell your phone the battery
level without having to have the earbuds
in there to make that transmission over
Bluetooth now the airpods 2 also have
the U1 Ultra wide band chip and that
gives you Precision finding so not only
will tell you if you're somewhat close
but it will guide you to your lost
airpods and if it's in a dark room that
led will Flash and with that you have
the speaker that will make a chime so
that is actually at least a 29 value
because you're practically have an air
tag built in but with a little bit more
features if you lose a third gen airpods
it's going to be much much harder to
find them thanks to those new Chips I
also found that switching devices is
much quicker and sometimes when you try
to period airpods you'll notice that it
doesn't switch over you have to tap it
now it just works so much faster with my
new iPhone 14 pro it is really nice as
far as controls the airpods Pro 2 also
give you that swiping feature now to be
honest in the last week I've only used
it one time and that is when I did not
have my Apple watch on me so I couldn't
just Spin My Crown to adjust my volume
but for a lot of people that don't have
an Apple Watch if you're used to asking
Siri to do it that is definitely nice to
have and now we have to talk about music
quality and that is the reason why I
ditched all the extra features of the
previous pros and went with the threes
because they sounded so much better well
this time around the pros sound
incredible I was a bit bummed when they
didn't show off that it doesn't have
dual drivers like Samsung's but when I
heard them for myself it is shocking how
good it is the airpods Pro 2 play as low
as 20 Hertz and they play it Loud the
airpods Pro 3 can play it but much much
quieter and these can actually play 15
Hertz like in this test track here where
you actually hear that and you feel that
and with the airpods 3 you don't hear
any of those low notes now with that
even though these are sealed The Sound
Stage is quite a bit better spatial
audio works better especially once you
optimize it and pretty much every track
that I listen to is better in every
single way it also plays louder without
Distortion and the separation between
instruments especially in heavy songs we
have a lot of tracks like rock music is
definitely better as well so if you have
these because you like the sound quality
I mean the airpods Pro 2 are on a whole
nother level so with all of that said If
you're trying to decide which one to buy
I would say that if you can afford to
spend 250 bucks or if they're discounted
I'll have a link down below you guys
could check the current price I would
pay the extra money compared to getting
a discounted pair of these is even for
the fact that you can find them if you
lose them and all those other benefits
it is just an amazing pair of earbuds
you guys let me know your thoughts down
below below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]